inflation in the countries that used the
euro has hit a record high of 8.1
the figure for may shows how life
continues to get more expensive for many
europeans
inflation has been rising for the last
year getting further and further away
from the european central bank's target
of two percent as you'll see here
originally it was supply problems caused
by the pandemic that kicked off the
climb but war in ukraine has caused food
and fuel prices to rise pushing up
inflation even further
want to get more on this let's speak to
chief economist at berenberg bank holger
schmieding great to have you with us
hogger as as ever i mean how does this
figure of uh 8.1
fit in with what we were expecting for
the eurozone
the inflation rate of 8.1 is slightly
above expectations but it does fit the
overall story for now inflation
pressures are still tilting to the
upside there is still quite a bit of
inflation pressure in the pipeline from
the price increases for energy for food
and from the supply chain disruptions
for now that is for the next few months
we cannot hope for a lot of respite
yeah there hasn't really been any sign
so far that this is going to slow down
is it so the european central bank
under more pressure to act
yes the european central bank is under
pressure to act but
part of the problem for the european
central bank is
that of course these high prices for oil
for food
also cut very much into consumer
disposable incomes consumers have to
spend more on energy and hence they have
less to spend on other things so put
differently this is a shock that drives
up prices but it also probably hits
economic growth which now at the moment
is stagnating and the european center
bank has to find a balance between these
two things higher prices but slower
growth or even stagnation and recession
risks so they probably decide to go
ahead with rate hikes but not be very
aggressive to not kill the economy
outright
so
that's the ecb but what about national
governments within the eurozone are they
doing their bit to try and bring down
inflation
well there's not much that governments
can do to bring down inflation directly
they have not much control over it what
many of them are fortunately doing is to
help people the most vulnerable with
subsidies
or with for instance a cut in petrol
taxes here and there what precisely
governments are doing differs from
country to country and not all of that
is quite rational i'm afraid but at
least governments by and large are doing
something to help the most severely
affected
so are we seeing because this talks
about the eurozone which is obviously
across more than a dozen countries um
are we seeing very different amounts of
inflation in different member states
then
yes the range is very very broad in
france inflation remains relatively
contained by the standards of other
countries which is partly because france
has a significant government
intervention into the energy markets
also because it does use nuclear energy
for which of course we do not see such a
spike in prices and on the other hand
are countries where
gas and oil plays a major share in the
uh distribution of what households spend
their money on these are for instance
the baltic countries where inflation
rates are significantly higher than the
eurozone average
okay hogish meeting chief economist at
berenberg bank as ever thank you for
joining us
you're most welcome
now outside of the eurozone but still in
the eu is hungary which is also fighting
its own inflation battle with the war in
ukraine right on their doorstep
hungarians are feeling the knock-on
effects more than most
new labels again
prices have sharply increased for coffee
it has nearly doubled since last year
i have just changed price tags and when
i saw by how much they have increased i
was stunned
the inflation rate for april stands at
9.5 in hungary one of the highest in
eastern europe
in an attempt to turn the tide the state
fixed the price for a few products for
instance for sugar
also this pack of flour and this bottle
of sunflower oil costs just as much as
last year now this is due to government
price caps which are in place until july
1st but keeping some prices artificially
down didn't change the overall inflation
for so many other products
consumers tell us they are paying about
40 more for their entire shopping basket
this is 500 for end this is exorbitant
the price of flour and oil means nothing
that's not what we live from
prime minister orban says prices have
gone up due to the war in ukraine and
sanctions imposed by the european union
which hungary is a member of and his
prize caps allegedly support the
families
the manager of this rural gasoline
station disagrees he must sell the fuel
for 484 in the litter that's about 1
year and 25 cents one of the lowest
prices in europe and another price cap
he can barely remain open cover rising
energy costs or pay salaries he says
we have a family too they need to be
supported too if i cannot bring money
home my family is not being supported
along with other privately owned
gasoline stations he sues the government
over alleged violation of their property
rights he sends
i find it outrageous that i must operate
this with laws and cannot close
says price caps won't help decrease
inflation without austerity measures
hungary's economic reality will become
non-manageable
the economic reality that we have a twin
deficit
we have a high inflation
that
nothing no good news are coming from the
world economy
the energy prices will remain high so
all these issues are there there and
this there is no real talk about that
the government has now made it clear
that it's bracing for an economic crisis
what's less clear is whether its
measures are effective to deal with it
you